as the whole fake big craze finally run
its course thank you Mr Gutfeld beyond
meat seeing its Revenue taking those
dive plunging 30 in the second quarter
as the man dries up for their meatless
burgers and sausages and this op-ed's
saying it's time to stick a fork in the
whole thing the fake meat fat fake meat
fat has finally been exposed as a
complete waste of money yeah uh you were
so eager to talk Mr exclamation point
you have thoughts on this fake first I
will defend Beyond me you know the first
attempt is never the good one I mean you
saw the Wright brothers footage
[Laughter]
yeah I did but you know what bothers me
most about this why does it have to be
fake meat we have not had a new food
group in ages like can you think of the
last time we've had a real new food
group why don't you just create a new
food group why do you have to pretend to
be meat you don't have to identify to be
a beef or a chicken or whatever why
don't you be yourself call yours to come
up with the new I want a new food group
since Dairy nothing since Dairy we are
stagnant in the food group like genre
you have a recommendation
we got chicken we've got well we need
something new how about glorg
write that down but now insects would be
I don't know glurg we need to have glurg
it's for breakfast everybody think of
their food food group when I come here
Dana you wanna you got to respond well
yeah first of all it's not meat and that
has been a real disservice to cattle
ranchers all across America yeah and
also people who raise chickens or the
fake pork I mean it's actually not so I
think that that's unfair and there
should be a law against it but actually
the law of the marketplace worked better
because nobody likes this stuff it's a
weird texture it's a weird color because
it like they put out color to make it
look like blood and then it makes me
like want to gag I can't take it yeah
and then today I was at a shop I got a
an almond milk latte which is not milk
it should be like almond juice or
whatever but on the board it said that
you could get a chicken tuna special I
was like what is I don't understand that
so it was like was the chicken fake or
the tuna fake I don't know but I'm glad
that just the the marketplace is taking
this is really tearing you apart yeah
this is just a get rich quick scheme and
I'm jealous you think these people are
dumb they're Geniuses they made millions
of dollars for the last five years
selling fake meat it's a pump and dump
it's fine the Stock's dropped and now
they've all gotten homes eat that stuff
it's going to be remember they also did
all of this because they claimed it was
a global warming issue right what what
doesn't make sense to me is if they hate
me so much why do they make fake meat
you know why don't they make something
else plus the other thing is it's Ultra
processed okay so it's not that good for
you plus um there's all kinds of energy
that's needed to make it and in the end
it's it's there's no benefit to it so I
think that we should have a blurb or
something different or maybe let's have
a darn hamburger I'm I'm I'm a hypoconus
because I'm a climate change guy but the
biggest emitters of carbon are cows and
concrete and I'm a gorillas hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else